i decided to get this man on this show
he had zero chill
in tweeting at knicks fans last night
watching them get eliminated in five on
the island of manhattan
sitting out there in brooklyn with kyrie
and durant and hardin and blake griffin
and more
is the tony award uh winner emmy award
winner golden globe award winner
jeffrey wright the actor and die hard
brooklyn nets fan here on the rich eisen
show how are you sir
i'm i'm hanging in there rich how you
doing i'm doing fine i figured you know
what let's get jeffrey on this show
and give voice to the brooklyn net fan
and what you think what are you thinking
right now
jeffrey right yeah yeah you know time to
heal the nation uh
one super team at a time yeah you know
it's all
it's all i you know i gotta laugh a
little bit it's pretty i i do find it
pretty funny because
yeah there's all this resentment there's
always hate you know toward the
nets but there is not an nba fan
anywhere in this country anywhere in the
world
who didn't want kd when free agency came
up who didn't want
kyrie on their team and now
you know everybody's whining because
yeah the nets are coming to town to
spank that booty so
like everyone wanted you know people
were floating out like
you know starting five lineups
speculative lineups with these dudes for
every team in the league so come on
i mean you know it is what it is and the
thing that people
i think fail to understand is that this
didn't just happened with the flip of a
switch
what's what's happened in brooklyn since
the nets got here
is that there's been an evolution of a
culture at that
organization and on that court a culture
of winning
that began to grow and to bloom and uh
that's what attracted these guys you
know you know from
from you know the time they hit in 2012
till you know 2019 when this happened
there's been there's been a vibe created
there
not only if i like you know in the arena
no
you know we don't throw bottles we don't
spit on people you know lately we just
bag the w
that's all we do but you know there was
a five there there was an attractiveness
there and there was a young
core team that had been developed that
was really starting to grind and that
that's what it was it was this culture
of winning that that started to emerge i
think
that was the reason that this was
possible so it didn't know
it didn't just happen overnight no and
and and
obviously again um it's it's difficult
certainly
certainly in the city and from what
you're calling right now um
from brooklyn where it's difficult even
for
the fans sitting there on the island of
manhattan that did watch their favorite
team go out in five last night
um that that team and that arena
was not the conduit for the super team
to form
forces you're right the nets did build
something with that
arena as well that made it more
attractive for those guys to go
there and team up i think it's just
people just can't handle the teaming up
aspect of it they just can't yeah well
but but the
knicks fans were dying for those guys to
be there
you know so it's a little bit cynical
but i get it as i said
but yeah and i think it starts to you
know with the nets really from the top
down you know they've got joe's side
there now and obviously deep pockets
yeah but
remember that guy was an athlete at yale
i don't
know him i've met him a couple times i
know him very well but he was an athlete
he played lacrosse as i did in college
you know
if you're a collegiate athlete you want
to win
right so you're establishing that now
that he's you know
gotten control over the team i have to
imagine
that like that falls down from the top
let's win
you know just win baby al davis style
you know so
the culture over at the next
organization
is not quite as clear you know or
certainly that hasn't been manifest in
the way it has been in brooklyn so
you know they've got a lot going from
you know sean marx over there
pulling together some guys you know over
these past years he's getting this
obviously a serious eye for talent
you think about the big three yes kyrie
you know uh
physicist you know uh kd daggers
and harden you know are you
you think about the i'll get the heart
in a second you think about those guys
but the role players
this year have uh have really
uh contributed in ways that are that
have been underappreciated you know guys
like
you know uh uh tyler johnson you know
had to step
up the times you know shaman yeah uh the
way that claxton has emerged
you know and and and joe harris for
example who
years you know a few years ago people
were going you know joe he's like oh you
know his name now
you know but these guys are playing
a huge role in the net success
and then getting them through this
season when there was some you know some
values that we dipped into you know
through injuries and the like so
you know this is a this is a larger
picture
than just these bad bad dudes
you know that make up this big three you
know and frankly with harden
yes i'm a hardened per second when that
possibility came up i have to say i was
i was like i'm like i don't know bruh
you know i don't know what's going on
down in houston
and the vibe seems you know kind of off
man i've never been so wrong in my life
that dude
is just a visionary man he's a visionary
on that corner in that court like seeing
things into being like
you know you know magic johnson style
and just and his feet his court
generalship you know is just
singular the guy's he's got the body
he's got the skills
but his mind and his vision you know
are what is really is really making the
difference
and the selfishness that he engenders
selflessness i should say
that he engenders among all these guys
all the guys the way they've been
playing you know everybody says ego
driven their self but no man this
they've been playing such generous
beautiful basketball and i i they
haven't even really hit it yet
but there were pockets during the season
where they hit it and then you know the
celtics they started so i don't know
everybody i don't think people should
really complain
yet because wait for it
and then maybe you can you know maybe
you can play again but it's not
it's not really on all cylinders
so everybody can calm down a little bit
jeffrey wright the emmy award-winning
actor tony award-winning actor
love his work many of us and westwood
and of course the new bond film that's
going to be coming out soon
uh right here on the rich eisen show so
where's the parade jeffrey where does it
take place do you go
do you go to manhattan do you do the
canyon heroes right in the knicks
backyard or you go like nostradamu you
do something
right there in brooklyn what do you do
we're we're nobody go to manhattan we
don't go to manhattan from brooklyn
you know
but you have to manhattan you know the
thing about the barclays center is that
it's become
kind of a uh you know a cultural hub in
other ways you know
a lot of the you know the protests uh
this summer you know with
against police brutality after the
george george fourth thing a lot of
those emanating from the barclays center
so there's a
you know there's a there's a there's an
energy there
and you know and up flatbush avenue and
up you know
that uh that who knows i don't know
where it is but uh
uh his damn strength gonna be in
manhattan well i think
i think you should start thinking about
it potentially look i mean but the bucks
the bucks are you know they looked like
an angry bunch
you know they looked like a bunch that
was um
on point and um
and this i can't wait this this is huge
and when you take a look
certainly if the lakers are out and i
understand that there's a ton of teams
that are very talented
but this is essentially certainly if
embiid is hurt this could be
it right this could be the it here this
i i really
think it is i mean i think this is for
everything and you know not to diminish
you know philly
really you know you know got you know
their their their their squad but you
know
you know the nets you know showed him a
few things this season you know
uh you know the questions about him be
you know embiid you know also
we'll see i think denver's tough you
know obviously
uh but you know the lakers you know
they're you know they're struggling
right now so
this you know this matchup
this is it and you know giannis is
giannis is giannis and he's going to do
giannios things there's no doubt about
it i mean that guy is on another
level so it's going to be difficult it's
going to be tricky and the nets have
some vulnerabilities you know we've got
vulnerability vulnerabilities in the
paint you know we don't have the beef
that
you know we we might want you know you
know to take care of business in there
we've we've definitely got some
vulnerabilities but
at the same time if these guys
you know and harden lately is starting
to you know starting to
hit long range if he gets hot long range
if joe harris is hot early
you know you can hear my dog barking in
the background because you know he knows
what it's about
if those guys start to really really
quick and hit shots
and keep up the intensity that they uh
that you know that they've shown over
these past games and
yeah you know we got we got you know
we got a shot i'm not gonna say it's
gonna be easy you know but it's gonna be
a war no doubt about it
it's gonna be fun so uh on a scale of
one to ten how incorrigible are you
gonna be with your nick friends
jeffrey oh i'm already awful
[Laughter]
i shot i shot spike attacks like you
know minutes after the game how'd that
go
yeah you know but you know it's all in
it's all it's all good of course
they're kind of rough man they're kind
of rough you know they throw a lot of
heat you know i'm just kind of
deflecting it back with the mirror
you know yeah i i i guess there's only
one team in new york now
and only one in brooklyn uh that was at
at j free wright yesterday i saw
you had very zero chill towards nick
fans on twitter which
was part of the reason why i reached out
to you because i i don't understand
why so many of many or your colleagues
in the uh
acting celebrity world just continue to
just put their hard-earned money in the
pocket of a man who let oakley rot in
jail overnight i just
just don't get it you can take a
courtesy car over to brooklyn and watch
three generationally brilliant players
maybe go out with a coach and steve nash
who uh
just because the everybody thinks he's
rolling the basketballs out wasn't even
put in the conversation with thibodeau
jeffrey
you know he's got the he's got the thing
you know he understands the psychology
of this man he was the right guy for
this
job but you're absolutely right you know
the oakley thing
was just like i mean come on what is
that
i actually had a guy in my neighborhood
roll up to me
with uh nick's shirt on 34 oakley
talking smack
i'm like bruh really you got to
leave jersey off right and and
regardless of the fact that you got
swept this year
you're going to step to me about this i
mean it's just
it's just yeah it's you know i'm a you
know i'm a i grew up in dc uh
you know as you know i'm a you know uh
uh uh wtf or the wft fan yes
it went from wtf to wft this year and
maybe beyond
actually yeah that's the thing yeah they
transposed those letters yeah right
right so i you know i know what it's
like to
to be uh you know uh loyal
to a dysfunctional and even
kind of malignant organization and i've
kind of stepped up but i'm not
i mean these guys you know yeah these
guys seem to overlook
a lot of that that oakley thing was
really really hard that's
i mean it's just uh it's just vulgar man
so anyway and then on top of that you
know you know you can't spit on people
man you can't you know and they're
calling out me you know they're calling
out they want in brooklyn but you know i
guess you know
we have to wait until uh the regular
season schedule next yeah
they will have to you know still have
brooklyn
so jeffrey right before i let you go are
you in the new space jam
are you in space jam too you got your
voice i am not i am not you're not
okay your imdb is is incorrect um so
then what is what are you working on
right now what's next for you
well you know uh i uh in fact i just got
as i was waiting uh to to ring you i
just got the first script for uh
westworld season four so we go back to
work in about 10 days
so there's that and you know i was over
in london uh until march finishing up
batman
and uh you know the nets were keeping me
uh keeping my brain
somewhat uh somewhat clear over there
you know a lot of isolation over there
during you know the quarantines and the
like
that games are keeping me pretty clear
and buoyant and stuff like that so
finish that going back to westworld now
and you know just trying to keep it
rolling bro i'm trying to make the
adjustment like everybody else
no doubt so uh and then the the new bond
film
got pushed due to covet when is that
coming out this fall is that when that's
oh yeah october uh okay the exact day in
october yeah should be out in october
you know continue uh according to plan
so uh yeah that'll be fun that'll be fun
to uh and i've got a wes
anderson film that i did uh that got
pushed back to that's opening can uh
opening cancer
festival this year as a live so you know
a couple things a little something for
everybody rich
yes so bond westworld wes
anderson and an nba championship
potentially for your brooklyn nets
that i'm trying to be like hard man i'm
trying to dish it out to everybody
and also make threes get to the line and
do everything else so uh that's right
jeffrey thanks for the call appreciate
it let's uh let's connect as your
your team uh potentially matriculates
cool man
thanks rich thanks for the call you bet
that's one of our favorites jeffrey
wright that was awesome
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here